In fact the this, this notion that there
are three receptors that are absorbing
light, refer, results in what's referred
to as the tristimulus color theory.
The idea is that it's three inputs.
And you know,
here it says the spectral-response
of each of the three types of cones.
Unlike the previous one where we're
showing you the relative sensitivity of
each of them, what this graph is
showing you, just as it says, this is
the percentage of light absorbed by
each cone, actually by each cone type.
The reason that even though blue is so
much more sensitive down here,
because there's so few blue cones.
The amount of light down here absorbed
by the blue cones compare to the amount
absorbed by red cones and green cones is
approximately equal because there's so
many more green cones and
red cones than there are blue cones.
So the question then is,
is can we, how, it says can,
but how would we use the outputs of,
of these three types of receptors
in order to see color,
in particular like spectral color.
And what I mean by spectral color is,
you're all familiar with this red,
orange, yellow, green,
blue, indigo, violet.
You probably learned that somewhere
along the way as the colors in
the rainbow.
Well what it really is, is these
are different wavelengths of light.
And those are the colors that you see
when those wavelengths are put out,
okay?
And I'll, I'll, I'll, we'll,
we'll see a little bit more about
what we mean by that, all right?